how are you doing today sir
i'm good sir how are you doing i have a
cat screaming outside my door hopefully
you don't hear her
[Laughter]
why is she so angry your cat what's
going on i think she's just desperate to
be part of this interview i mean she's a
big fan of your work
i can't blame her listen i i can't blame
her
stop bogarting me let the cat in man
so let me start by saying i saw your
film yesterday and i really enjoyed it
and i you have a knack of writing
dialogue that feels very realistic
and i'm just curious how do you manage
to sort of capture realism like that and
put it on the page
um well first of all i have to equally
credit my co-writers tama bitigan and
noe debre because they
they were very much a part of all that
dialogue and all that work with me but
thank you for that
um you know i think some of it is just
research right and sort of finding and
by that i don't just mean like
book research but spending time with
people spending time with people in this
world be it
uh bill from oklahoma be it roughnecks
uh
be it uh people in marseille uh and just
sort of immersing myself in the culture
as a writer it's one of my favorite
things to do just show up kind of drop
in start to make connections and with
this one some of those connections were
built up over
years right and and really just sort of
listening to the rhythms and the sounds
and uh the tone of the people i'm
writing
uh and then letting that infuse over
time so um
you know it's something i love doing i
love trying to find it i love trying to
be as efficient as possible with it
as minimal as possible that when i can
um
but you know it's really one of the
great joys when those characters start
to come alive and talk you know it's
just
it's one of the thrills of the job quite
frankly
here's my curveball for you uh if you
get the financing for any project
tomorrow
what would you make and why oh man
look i felt that way about stillwater
right like i wrote this script
and um you know i pitched it first to my
friend steve golan who's now passed away
steve's one of the producers on the
movie in this very hotel that i'm giving
this
interview from right now we had lunch
and down there and i said i got this
movie about a roughneck who goes to
marseille to get his daughter out of
prison
it's going to be somewhat like a
redemption story but it's going to have
more dimension he's like i'm in
and uh that's how life should be right
like and somehow that remained true we
found partners at participant and david
lindy he read the script he's like i'm
in
now you've seen the movie it's a
complicated movie right it defies
genre and expectation i think in ways
it's going to be exciting
and challenging for audiences but like
the fact that these people stepped up in
such a way and said go make your movie
go to marseille make your movie you want
to make like i feel so fortunate to do
that so
i got to start with stillwater i still
sometimes pinch myself
that i was able to go make that movie
and make it with matt damon and
i mean that wholeheartedly like when i
watch the movie it can
you know 100 miles from where we shot it
i'm like man i can't believe we got to
do this
especially now after a year and a half
of being locked up in my house
i'm like man the fact that i got to go
live in france and make
exactly the story i wanted to we all
felt lucky
matt me the crew the guys who i've
worked with in the past
we all felt like man you don't get a
chance to do things like this very often
in your career
so i you know yeah i could guess what
that other film could be but i got to
acknowledge
i think the blessings i had to go make
this movie it was just it was uh
i felt fortunate i liked the way how you
shot this film
and in oklahoma it was like static shots
anamorphic lenses you go to marseille
and it's
you know more handheld you had a very
specific aesthetic choices uh where you
were filming the movie can you sort of
talk about why you wanted
uh this camera work and the way you shot
it yeah it was just sort of
you know feeling that a little bit more
you know uh
space around bill with the anamorphic
specifically
in oklahoma and feeling him a little bit
more rooted to the ground right a little
more
of the earth which is what bill is as
opposed to when we go to marseille and
we start feeling the sea
and the sky and the light of marseille
and um you know we don't spend a lot of
time in oklahoma and we really two
things had to happen one
we really needed to feel the differences
and the uh
of the space and the energy the visual
energy of those spaces need to be really
clearly defined
two which is a little off point is matt
damon's performance right like
matt had to come we only spend four
minutes in oklahoma before we drop him
into marseille
he needed to be there fully formed fully
dimensional for us to really appreciate
this man's journey
but to go back to your visual like that
was the idea once we got off that plane
in marseille
and we're sort of mysteriously following
this roughneck who seems to know exactly
where he's going in this very specific
city
um we wanted to not only feel the
mystery of that but the energy of that
uh and that's when we started going
handheld and and steady for almost the
entire movie
until we returned to oklahoma um that
was very much
uh by design it's something my dp and i
massa
nobutakinagi talked a lot about
i'm always obsessed with learning about
the editing because that's the final
rewrite and ultimately it's where the
movie comes together it's make or break
uh can you talk about the challenges you
encountered in the editing room
did you ever have a radically different
version or you know a different version
of certain storylines
no what we had was a lot more movie on
this one we shot a lot of movie
we i needed to because i knew i wasn't
going to go back to marseille with matt
it was going to be too hard to organize
that and
and we just had a lot of scripts so it
was really finding that and you know i
credit my
my editor tom mcardle he's edited all my
films i think of him as a
fourth writer on this project and um you
know he just has
a real way of distilling distilling and
distilling and getting to the essence of
the movie and pushing on me
to push on my own script and my own
notions of the picture
i think what was really interesting
about this one was that like because we
shut down you know we're almost done
with the movie
the march going into the shutdown of
covid and we let it go we didn't pick it
up again until august tom came out we
edited in my basement for a while which
was super cool
and uh and then we shut it down again
and we picked it up
this past february uh really february
march probably to finish the movie and
complete it for can
but we had these breaks of like four or
five months and it was
super interesting for a movie this
complex with this many
threads and this many lanes to be able
to stand back and look at the movie
fresh and be like
okay what what what is essential here
and what is not
and where are we losing our audience and
where are we you know where are we doing
it right
um having that space from the movie and
then being able to look at fresh was
incredibly helpful did you ever have
like a three hour
cut that you were like super happy with
305 i think
really um but you know by the way the
studio never was like you know get your
cut down get your cut down they were
just like
you know we were doing it to ourselves
in fact we went out to show
we went out to show the studio that
caught last march right before the
shutdown
they were super happy with the movie and
it was about 20 minutes longer
now they knew we weren't done working on
it but tom and i came back like he's we
had to watch it three times with each
with participant with focus and one
other time and we got back
and make making ourselves watch it fresh
with people we're like all right we know
what we got to do we took 20 minutes out
of the movie like that
and it wasn't dropping any one
particular scene you know so
um it you know you're right to focus on
editing it's just such a you know
obviously critical but just
to me it's always fascinating how like
you think you're done and then you
reapproach something
there's one montage sequence about three
quarters of the way through the movie
um that shows sort of matt lang deeper
into marseille
and we did not get that right we did not
get that sequence right until about
two weeks from finishing editing after
about a year and a half
total and it just took time we just
couldn't see it before that
and thank goodness we had the time even
though it was not for the right reasons
necessarily
i have to stop there i'm just going to
say congrats on the film i hope it's a
big hit for you guys
thank you thank you thank you for your
time